[Laughter]
what did you do that for
uh that's the easy fix i got i have a
screwdriver
in the car i thought about doing
stand-up comedy you tell jokes
it's pretty scary to come up here i have
a friend who's been wanting to try to
stand up but he's a little chicken
dave is my best friend good day i'm so
scared right now
most of the time i felt like they were
married and i was just a bystander
hey buddy it's matt want to see how you
were doing hi brilliant
[Music]
mom hi girls
hi froot loop hey how you feeling tired
thanks for being here i won't miss it
can we talk for a minute matt it's going
to get very hard you're going to see
things from nicole
never seen before you don't need to do
this alone i can come and help you get
to the other side of this we'd love to
have you
how long did you feel me up there i'm
hoping just a couple weeks just want to
make sure matt gets back on his feet
i usually make breakfast and dinner
maybe you can take some of that weight
off
speaking of i was hoping you'd call me
grandma dane sure molly
excuse me sure i'll call you grandma
dang thank you
i want to make a list i'd like to write
letters to the girls for certain
milestones in their lives
i want to have blue hair molly tell me
when it's happening it's not happening
her entire life she's wanted to be the
grand marshal of mardi gras
and i want to sing on stage with katy
perry
it all seems pretty doable does it
you've been gone for three months now i
thought that you were going to be gone
for a couple weeks
what changed i got here and i saw that
one person can't do this job
i'm still about that person
i don't think you're this upset because
i'm late what's happening to mom i think
you're mad because mom is sick
why you so hard on your dad
mother you've broken my body i saw your
look at me when they smile to me anymore
you're the most beautiful one
you'll always feel me
you know you don't have to stick around
nicole's my best friend too i'm happy to
be here
you